care anymore about family party i will
never now i don't think i'll ever attend
it
i don't think i can uh attend like
another family event i have to create a
new film that's so exciting that's so
exciting
and it will be arabs and jews and jews
people that own real estate and people
that sell diamonds
arabs and jews arabs and jews
they don't get along but they're not
cops and firefighters arabs
and jews they're not pigs with flesh
diseases
like my irish big family
beverly hills tanner pal
i don't care kind of cold
do business with your family
[Music]
i was raised in the 70s the 70s were a
very different time the 70s everything
was different in the 70s than it is now
except
the middle east is exactly the same it's
exactly the same as it was in the 70s
it's been the same fights and you know
what it's boring now that's the worst
part of it
when i was a kid we were like but you
can't go like this
for like a thousand years after a while
when you fight people don't care because
when you're just both you just keep
fighting everybody's like those guys are
dicks they just
fight that's what it's like you know
like i have two kids and they fight
sometimes
and when they first start fighting i get
concerned i go in the room i'm like hey
what's going on
what's wrong why are we having some
feelings
can we can we listen to each other
please can we please just listen to each
other okay you go first and then she
goes she's like
yeah that sounds hard
okay okay thank you thank you okay now
you
because i like this one a little more
and they work it out you help them work
it out but if they keep fighting
you stop doing that after a while you
just go in the room and you just go hey
just shut up you're both wrong
because he won't stop fighting you're in
a family there's other people in this
family
and you're being a couple of selfish
little [__] that won't fix anything
you share a room we can't afford another
room so just deal with it
somehow this has to do with israel in
palestine i don't know exactly
it is because my kids are like israel
and palestine
and i'm like america the little ones
like palestine because she always gets
screwed she gets the worst deals
she's like she threw a rocket in my face
i'm like you're fine
look you have a great life you take a
rock to the face once in a while you're
fine
the older one is like israel she comes
at me she burns all my dolls i'm like
look i can't do anything about it right
now
your sister is crazy please don't make
me talk
i'll work it out you and me okay we'll
go out
i'll buy you a really cool missile and
you do whatever you
want what can you do with it it's
totally up to you
i did a tour recently called around the
world in eight days
we went to uh iraq afghanistan germany
turkey
greenland alaska and los angeles
they had to drop me off iraq was crazy
guys when you land in iraq it's not like
landing here you know in el paso where
the plane comes in
over there people take shots at the
planes so the plane comes in like this
like that and then at the last minute
the whole plane someone like
chimichangas it was terrible
[Applause]
that for me was one of the scariest
shows of my life man
i'm in iraq middle of the night
outside no tent
pitch black helicopter flying and
there's a spotlight
on me and i'm supposed to be funny and i
can hear
and the crazy part is that i saw a sign
that was very familiar
they have subways in iraq
i was like is that what is it is that
it's subway oh my god
yeah i got back to my room they have the
stupid commercial there too
in their language oh my god i almost
lost it same one freaking holly holly
haley
[Applause]
i want people to come to where
i grew up and experience the glory
the glory of the lebanese father
they'll have the same phone for like 15
years
they get they're proud you get a new
phone look at you
i have this phone for 15 years
15 years look how good it is
hello
never forgot i got my dad an iphone a
few years ago
got him an iphone for his birthday i was
so excited i give him the phone
he looks at it he's like you got me a
mirror
you know that it's a phone really really
really it's a
no but what do i shout at it what do i
do like no dad it's a touch phone you
touch the phone he's like
he throws the phone i'm like what's
wrong he's like 33 years i touched no
one but your mother
now you want me
[Applause]
that it's a it's a touch i show him how
to use it he was so amazing he's
americans barack obama this is
it's made in china but sure okay what
i teach how to use the phone we go
through the ritual which i think is
universal where you have to help your
parents choose the ringtone takes about
two and a half to three hours on average
cycle through every this oh no go back
no this one was good
this is done here do you remember this
so this was can we put it on cd i like
this put in the card
until we finally decide on the default
ringtone
that comes with the iphone
but it's okay i won't have to do this
for another 30 40 years
it's fine he's my dad what's important
is he's happy
i leave the house i get in my car i'm
driving away i'm like you know i want to
call my dad first phone call
so i pick up the phone i call him it
rings
no answer as an arab if you call a loved
one and they don't answer
they're dead this is what it means it's
not our fault it's our moms
that's they overreact let's be called my
son
he was such a good boy
start wearing black you come back home
but i was like never push down the arab
side bring up the american
relax you got this i waited like 10
minutes
called him again he didn't answer now
he's dead there's no way
say there's no possible reaction so i
start driving back to my dad's house
calling constantly ringing ringing
ringing
in my mind i'm like what do i my mom
wasn't in the country i was like do i
tell mom
dad's dead or do i tell her i can't cook
some lebanese like mushadra and then she
comes on my good news i can cook himself
and i'm like oh my boy i'm like my dad's
dead oh my god don't you like what do i
i get to my dad's house i get in front
of the door and i'm like never take just
every guy has to go through this be a
man you'll mourn later
i put the key in the door just before i
open them like let me try one more time
i call him i hear the phone ringing
and i hear a weird shuffling noise and
then it stops and i'm like
he just down just that was it that was
his last
i prepared myself to walk in seems on
the floor hand outstretched
just within reach of the phone
i put in the key took a deep breath i
opened the door and i saw my dad
standing in the hallway just sweating
from head to toe holding the phone like
that why aren't you answering he's like
what is this piece
like what's wrong he's like it tells me
slide to answer i'm doing this and this
and what the michael jackson
who lost it
[Music]
you